[Musique]
du 4 au 6 mai aura lieu le championnat
de france de raids multisports unss qui
cette année se déroulera à la réunion à
quelques jours de la compétition nous
nous sommes rendus à la bretagne suivre
l'entraînement de l'équipe du collège et
milito
j'avais vraiment quand il ya une bonne
entente dans les tous mais qu'on fait
une activité de groupe et c'est bien le
cas l'ex
c'est un petit peu de pression mais pas
beaucoup enfin tête sur le thème est la
non par moments entre midi et deux on
allait s'entraîner à courir les
week-ends on s'entraîne plus que
d'habitude tout ça fait depuis les
vacances de décembre qu'on s'entraîne
trois fois par semaine et du coup on se
connaît assez préparés pour la
course d'orientation kours la rou vtt au
programme de leur entraînement à kraft
trahi les épreuves combinées seront
également à la fiche du championnat
depuis que j'ai rejoint l'équipe des
mets locaux se prépare un avantage c'est
à nous de jouer à domicile pour les sept
équipes très mignon
non oui ça beaucoup davantage parce
qu'en fait tu m'as déjà préparation à la
course la roue et puis ils vont avoir un
petit peu de public et par an
les parents matelas des copains à
chaleur sans visage à leur vie au moins
on a envie d'aller chercher quelque
chose donc piot ils sont hyper motivés
ça nous motive aussi personnellement je
suis hyper motivé pour essayer d'aller
d'aller chercher quelque chose et qui
vivent une expérience incroyable ce sont
les soixante deux meilleures équipes des
collèges de l'hexagone et d'outre-mer
qui participeront à cette manifestation
qui réunira 380 jeune rider encadrés par
près de 200 enseignants
maintenant on peut je pense à aj - 7
dévoilé certaines choses c'est à dire
qu'il ya trois zones de trois zones de
d'activité en zone de raid avec un
prologue qui se déroulera à sainte
suzanne sur le site du bocage de nuit
donc après l'épreuve partira 18h30 pour
une arrivée de
les derniers coureurs va
11h23 heure et puis le premier jour se
fera dans l'est donc avec une identité
très marqué sur ce territoire de la côte
est entre bras panon et saint benoît
avec un final sur l'île de coco et puis
des sections de de très original de pâte
kraft derrière deux bateaux gonflables
dans les dans les rivières que soient
les marsouins que ce soit aussi
également un passage en canyon dans la
rivière des roches y
est le troisième jour donc oui bien sûr
pas bon le troisième jour aura lieu sur
la côte ouest avec un départ du sommet
du maïdo et puis une arrivée au camping
de l'ermitage
avant le coup d'envoi des épreuves les
collégiens participeront à une séance de
sensibilisation de l'environnement
ponctuée de la signature d'une charte
d'engagement de leurs représentants ce
lundi 2 mai à mascara un jardin
botanique
[Musique]